we had big news this morning big news
yesterday Elon Musk outed this FBI agent
who was a former disgraced FBI agency or
he is a former FBI agent and disgraced
he becomes Deputy general counsel at
Twitter Elon Musk boots him out
we have this tweet from John Hassan he
says in the last two months the feds
have launched investigations into Nora
link Twitter and Tesla sure seems like
Elon Musk is being targeted this is a
good news right we may be we may be
looking at some really bad stuff
happening Elon the big story from this
morning I guess Elon musk's tweet
confirms he's added staff beds at
Twitter HQ but insists he's just helping
tired employees framing it like this big
negative thing and now we're hearing
that SF is actually going to be
investigating as if he's you know
mistreating his employees or something
this is a good news you know why the
fact that we can see how obvious and
Brazen it is it didn't used to be this
way they used to be able to get away
with this stuff control smash destroy
they would character assassinate or you
know maybe even actually assassinate
people and now they're struggling to
even go after one dude who bought a
social media Network I I I get it he's
the richest guy in the world or was and
he bought Twitter which was one of the
biggest social media platforms so he's
not just a guy but they're struggling to
get it done they can't go after him so
you know this morning I was talking
about or earlier today
we got all this crime we got uh you know
California shutting down their third
prison they're just releasing everybody
and all this stuff sounds really really
bad but I actually think we should look
at it in a positive light the system is
is breaking down the corrupt people are
failing California crime is through the
roof they can't figure out they're
getting everything's getting worse the
FBI the feds they want to go after Elon
Musk they're failing he just gutted the
collusion between big Tech and social
media so I'm feeling pretty good what
about you guys I I like what he's doing
with Twitter and everything but I'm not
gonna lie
um he gives me Revelation 13 Vibes so if
they investigate nerd link shut it down
some type of way and they are doing this
just to attack Elon Musk but listen man
I watched Elon Musk interviews for years
this man literally said he wants
everybody to have access to any
information with just a thought you know
so he said he said it's we can't beat AI
so he wants us wants us to combine with
it and now he's you know promoting that
it could fix a lot of diseases that
sounds like great wonders and if you
read Revelation 13 then it just fits it
but everything else is gay so you're not
a fan of the microchip you're not going
to be implantica in your head and having
the mark of the beast inside of there no
sir I did a documentary advice and uh
the the girl she showed me her chip and
she did it and like you can see it in
there and I was like Wow demonic I said
it to her too you remember when Alex
Jones was talking about this 15 years
ago yeah and he was like people listen
they're going to put chips in you you're
gonna do your chips and I was watching
that this was back in like 2008 or
something and I was like this guy's
crazy like prisonplanet.tv or whatever
the website was back in the day I was
there screaming with him yeah very very
chip I think and then there were like
videos of people and they put their hand
up to the door and stuff like that they
really tried to do that again during
covet nobody wanted to do it now you
mean to tell me you couldn't get people
to put a little a little thing in their
hand to open doors and pay and you think
that they're going to take a computer
chip and put it in their brain
I think we're close to a future where
parents are going to have to fight with
their kids about becoming Immortal or
not you know their kids are gonna be
like I want to put it in my brain and
upload my Consciousness onto a computer
and I'm gonna have to be like no you
can't well and they're going to be mad
about me for saying no Tim we also have
to understand you know it's not that a
lot of people are going to be willingly
doing this it's that a lot of people are
going to be forced to do this whether
they like it or not to comply with the
larger social credit score and even
though it didn't work before with a lot
of fear-mongering surrounding global
warming even though it didn't work with
covid right now I think the next step
the next level of what they're going to
try to do is to crash the economy and
use that in order to push in a central
bank digital currency then that's going
to bring in the social credit score then
that's going to bring in the total
totalitarian system that they've been
testing in China and are going to
introduce everywhere around the world
bass Luke I think covet covet also
ushered in these people being more
willing to put chips in their brain with
like everyone's digital identities you
know you mean more to them I think a lot
of people will sign up actually you're
right man I'm gonna walk that statement
back about people not wanting to bring
chips um that's that's too like uh Echo
chamber insular you take a look at
what's going on in these cities man I'd
be willing to bet people would shove
stuff right up their ass like if the
government told them to do it no the
girl I mean there's there's a video
we'll get to in a minute where a guy's
wearing a mask and someone not wearing a
mask walks past him the guy freaks out
and starts trying to fight the guy like
I'm telling you man I I go to this I was
in Frederick Maryland the other day and
I'm seeing people wearing masks and it's
and it's it's scary it like it actually
creeps me out like yo what are you doing
do you eat here listen listen the
science has changed okay the science has
changed they're they're coming out now
there's a bunch of arguments about masks
being ineffective and all that stuff but
there are still people wearing 57 masks
all over their bodies but Tim what you
mentioned I just want to quickly
interject here especially what your
previous point about injecting stuff up
the you know what that the butt is that
is a family-friendly show here that is
already happening in China with the
swabs that they're using in order to
test individuals with that they violated
the U.S uh um U.S embassy employees with
that I just saw a horrible video where
they just took an old lady and they just
forced one of those swabs in there as
well
that's what they're doing in China
the U.S consulate was complaining about
U.S embassy workers being forcefully and
violently tested in China or covid up
there you know what we were talking
about this last year I was screaming
about this I was like I was I was
foretelling this for many years to come
and it is here now there's a reason they
have U.S military members walk around in
heels okay this is a slow
loyal to some a lot of crazy nonsense
did you guys see the the guy who said he
was retiring and he was wearing the dog
mask or whatever yeah yeah but I just
want to point out real quick I want you
to imagine that you're like walking down
the street in New York in 2015 and
Luke's holding a big sign being like the
butt swaps are coming they're gonna
shove it up here but they are and
they're doing that right now in China
they're testing it in China they're like
let's see what we could get away with in
China oh the U.S embassy the embassy is
here let's test it on on them they were
complaining about how bad it hurts
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no not wiping
people who see the future like that are
like Alex like they always sound insane
to everyone living in like the now but
reality is collapsed clearly like we're
not defining it as how we should be like
the world is done I'm sorry well that's
why I'm laughing you know it looks like
you're laughing but it's happening I
know we're laughing it's um it's the the
kicker guard thing the cloud comes out
on the stage and says there's a fire
broke out and everyone starts laughing
and clapping and then it gets frantic
and panic's not saying no no there's
actually a fire that everyone claps and
cheers and uh that's happening right now
he said I think that's how the world
will end we're the clowns oh you know
you know yeah in the world people will
make memes about it if there's like a
big bomb coming they'll be like 100
memes on Twitter in seconds did you see
that know that there's a meme where it's
like uh it's a post-apocalyptic City and
there's two guys sitting in the rubble
and one guy hands a picture to the other
guy and it's a meme like just yeah we're
there you gotta keep it going you know
you gotta you gotta try to laugh a
little bit Yeah so so look though Luke
you bring up a really good point uh
I look at everything that's going on
with people mindlessly zombie about it
was a story I told the other day
during during lockdown like a year and a
half ago or whatever I went to a sushi
restaurant with my girlfriend in
Frederick and we walked in and it's very
small like these are small old buildings
and I was probably about 10 feet away
from a chair and they like you got to
put a mask on if you want to come in
nobody anywhere is wearing a mask
wearing because they're eating and they
they told us that we had to leave if we
didn't wear them and I'm just like
complying with this level of psychosis
let's let's bring it back to Elon Musk
yeah the government's going to come out
and they're going to say if you want to
fly you got to get your your real neural
link ID and then they're going to be
like just get it they'll have to start
with something simple right it'll be
something on your phone it'll be like if
you don't have a phone we'll give you
one right now you can get Android phones
for like 20 bucks like really really
cheap they're low end but they work so
they'll be like if you don't have one
then you can apply and we'll give you
one and then you got to have this thing
on it then they're going to give you
some kind of like EEG sensor thing to
wear to like do like an EEG biocheck
then eventually they're going to be like
if you want the upgrade and you want to
fly first class for free then you got to
get the direct implant it's like the
people who sign up for car insurance
that allow the insurance company to like
gauge how you're doing right it's like
they have an insight and they can mess
with like your your rates and stuff
through that yeah yeah next level they
put a computer chip in your car and they
track your movement make sure you're not
speeding make sure you're stopping at
stop signs watch every single movie they
make it sound good now the next level of
that is Tesla insurance with cameras
that are looking inside of you as you're
driving making sure looking inside side
of the vehicle as you're driving making
sure that of course you are not abusing
the the cell phone but they can turn
your car off yeah based on what we were
just talking about you got to clarify
what you mean by camera inside of you
that's true was it four inches
the details here matter
so yeah uh I got Tesla insurance and my
rates went down because I'm a good
driver and because the car drives itself
so it's like you know you get in the car
you press the button and then you just
sit there and the car just drives itself
you gotta worry but here's the crazy
thing there's a camera pointed at you
while you're driving and if you look at
like if you try to change the music it
goes like and it says like pay attention
to the road no no yeah most uh it's not
as intrusive as other companies other
country uh other companies are a little
bit more intrusive where they watch your
eyes where they watch your face to make
sure it's always focused on the road uh
and then they take away the special
abilities if you don't comply with it so
I think Ford is already doing this and I
think Mustang is already doing this as
well someone correct me if I'm wrong
here because I'm just going off what I
read a couple months ago but this is
technology out there that's even beyond
what Tesla has well Tesla if you if you
don't keep your eyes on the road it will
disable auto drive what yeah I thought
it was just your hands and the and
pressure someone hack a Tesla oh yeah
do you think you think the CIA didn't
have the technology years and years ago
of course Michael Hastings Michael
Hastings right Bryson Bryson you got a
car yes is it is it is it after is it a
2010 or older yeah your car can be
remote controlled cap
yeah no not my
2013 Kia Soul my G uh I think anything
after 2010 can be fully remote
controlled what and now they're passing
regulations where you can't go over a
certain speed limit in Europe where they
have black boxes where they listen to
everything watch everything uh and we'll
be be able to take full control of your
car in Europe that's some of the
legislation that they're passing over
there essentially allowing the
government to hack and control every
aspect of your Driving Experience so
we're sitting here being like how dare
they go after Elon Musk oh also he's
doing really crazy scary stuff thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time